it's been more than a year since the war
in Ethiopia's t region ended people here
are still trying to cope with its
effects on them and their
economy and a prolonged rought is making
their lives even harder in the village
of atsby many families are
struggling I used to farm to feed my
family and get medical treatment for my
child who has mental issues no rain
means I can't farm and can't afford to
buy
medication after humanitarian Aid into
the region was disrupted help is now
reaching some communities but local
officials say much more is
needed we as the state government we do
not have any budget to assist we even
have not paid our government employees
for the last 15 months it's a very
complex issue and we do not have any
capacity to
help the interim Regional administration
of Tigra says approximately 2 million
people are at risk of starvation another
5.2 million need food
Aid water sources are drying up and what
people have left they use sparingly as
none of them know how long this crisis
were lost har matasa Alazar